I found a thread on Reddit that was five
questions to ask yourself if you're
unsure about your
relationship if someone told you you're
a lot like your partner would this be a
compliment to you are you truly
fulfilled or just less lonely are you
able to be unapologetically yourself or
do you feel the need to show up
differently to please your partner are
you in love with who your partner is
right now as a whole or are you only in
love with their good side their
potential or the idea of them and would
you want your future or imagined child
to date someone like your partner and
this thread was just filled with people
having existential crisis and it seemed
to me to
be a collection of people who had
managed to believe that continuing to
Manana Manana the
short-term postponement of the
discomfort of the decision that they
wanted to have around their partner uh
was somehow the noble thing thing to do
or the good thing to do or The Virtuous
thing to do or the thing that ultimately
would result in the best outcome even
though they knew that if they spread it
out long enough and then it's just
hidden we just shoven under the rug so
yeah that uh list of five questions I
think uh well in most relationships you
can break up or you can have a thousand
fights you know and if you have a
thousand fights then you don't have to
fight you make peace that way you know
because you're different than your
partner so there's things to work out
there and you might think about that as
a compromise but it's not it's
that you're different than your partner
and you have to find a game that you
both want to play that's not a
compromise that's a solution it's like
you bring your skills to the table and I
bring my skills to the table and then we
figure out some game we can play where
we're both optimally utilized and it's a
better game than we could play alone
that's not a compromise well but getting
to that's very difficult and people
bring all sorts of baggage to a
relationship and you have to it's just
like like disciplining children really
it's the same thing your children are
you note your children are annoying you
you can note that oh there I'm being
annoyed by my child okay so what
questions do you ask am I a tyrannical
son of a who's touchy well that's
why you need your wife cuz you can go
ask her my kids are annoying me am I a
tyrannical son of a who's touchy
and she said yeah you probably need
something to eat or you're a bit of a
prick that way and you got to listen
because maybe it's you or maybe she says
yeah that goddamn child's been getting
on my case too and then you ask each
other are we mutually tyrants it's like
no that kid's annoying okay do we want
him to be
annoying well if you love your child
then the answer that would be no because
if he's annoying you he's going to annoy
other people he's going to annoy his
potential friends he's going to annoy
other adults he's going to go through
the world being annoying and everyone's
going to frown at him that's not helpful
so then you could just fix it and you're
that's going to going to cause some
short-term upset you know you're maybe
you have a like a 13-month-old child
who's very extroverted and disagreeable
who like rules the roost and every time
the mother goes more than a foot away
from her she has a squawk fit because
she's learned to control maybe the
mother you know is still tied up with
infant care and can't put down a
boundary and so now you have to do
something about this emerging monster of
a 14-month-old child and one of the
things you do is every time the child is
bossy first of all you note it and you
note that you're not very fond of
yourself for being tyrannized by a
14-month-old that's a bit of a status
hit like it should be so you have to
notice I'm annoyed by this child then I
should do something about it well it's
going to cause short-term emotional
distress the same thing occurs when
you're dealing with your partner it's
like you're annoying me okay now maybe
that's me so I should bloody well maybe
we should have a talk about that you're
annoying me convince me that it's me and
I should listen because maybe it's me
and if I'm annoyed about you and I
shouldn't be I should fix that but maybe
it's you so let's find out exactly
what's going on you know and that'll
usually man that's that'll there's just
constant thrust and counter thrust in a
discussion like that and usually you
know the conversation will circle around
whatever the hell the issue is till you
get to the bottom of it and God only
knows where that is is but then maybe
you can sort it out you know and if you
sort out enough of those things you live
in peace and that's something worth
attaining you know and I've thought
forever in my marriage there's nothing
there's nothing too small to fight about
now you know I put in some rules that I
used to have with my clients too it's
like if someone bugs you you should note
that and you shouldn't do anything about
it probably if they bug you twice the
same way then you think oh okay that's
twice but probably still you shouldn't
do anything about it but if they bug you
three times then you can
say here's what you just did and they'll
say well no I didn't do that and then
you say yeah you did and you did exactly
the same thing in this other situation
and you did exactly the same thing in
this other situation so don't be telling
me you didn't do it cuz you did it three
times and I watched okay now they come
up with reasons they did it and maybe
some of them have to do with what is
stupid son of a you are and you
should listen because maybe they're
right but that's at least the beginnings
of the process by which you unravel the
problems you want to figure out well we
don't want to do this this isn't the way
we want to treat each other we want to
get to a place
where we want to get to a place where
our whole life is like the best moments
of the best dates we ever
had that's a good goal and that's that's
that's Attain able it you got to work
man there's there's a the scene in the
in
Genesis God throws Adam and Eve out of
paradise because of their pride their
sin of
Pride they each have their own
particular version of that sin Eve's sin
and Adam's but they get thrown out of
paradise anyways for pride and God puts
cherubs at the gates of paradise and the
cherubs they're kind of these monstrous
Angels terrifying figures and they hold
swords that are on fire that turn Every
Witch Way and burn and you might say
well what does that mean and it means
that well a sword is something that cuts
away right a sharp blade and a and fire
is something that burns and a sword that
Burns Burns and cuts away and a sword
that burns and
turns every which way is a burning sword
from which nothing can
escape okay now you want to walk into
Paradise everything that isn't worthy in
you has to be burned and cut away right
well that's what that conflict is in a
relationship you know it's like that's
not suitable for Paradise what does it
have to do it has to be cast into the
outer Darkness where there will be
nashing of teeth right it has to be cut
away and destroyed and everything that
isn't worthy has to go
well the Michelangelo effect is all
about you and your partner becoming the
idealized version of each other right
you are going to do for me the things
that I want within your parameters of
control that you want to be the best
partner for me and I want to do the same
for you we're both going to communicate
to each other and we're going to stand
our ground where we have boundaries and
we're going to continue to compromise
that's what love should do yeah that's
what love should do like if you love
someone if it's genuine love
you
see you see their hidden Soul that's a
good way of thinking about it you get a
glimpse of the light that they could
reveal to the world if they revealed it
that's what you see and then to act in
love is to encourage that to come
forward and to discourage anything that
gets in its way that's why I love the
the Michelangelo effect I'd heard of and
i' been using it okay so why the
Michelangelo effect this is why
Michelangelo sees this huge massive UNH
block I see I see and inside of that he
is able to see David M and over time
slowly he will chip away and he will
chip away and he will chip away so you
see something that isn't there that's
inside of the thing which is rough and
UNH and uncivilized and undomesticated
and rambunctious and and sometimes
terrible and you were able to from that
yeah that's actually part of the D Ching
the uncarved block so a child is an
uncarved Block in in in The dowst View
and and you remove everything that's
excess until what's perfect remains
right and that's see the the logos in
the Old and New Testament the logos that
creates the world is the judging faculty
that what would you say that separates
the wheat from the
chaff right and it's not it's compassion
in a sense because if you're
compassionate towards someone you want
what's best for them all things
considered but that compassion in the
highest sense can't exist without
judgment because the judgment is this
part of you isn't worthy to continue and
certainly that's what you're doing with
your children when you see them
misbehaving you think no that's no not
that not that something more
sophisticated even with my little
granddaughter the other day she's very
very playful and she's a very nice
little girl she's very playful and very
fun and funny and not neurotic and so
she's a pleasure to be around but she
hasn't seen me for a while and so she
was poking me getting me to chase her
around and poking me and she'd come up
and give me a whack you know and at one
point she whacked me too hard and she
knew it and I said that's not fun that's
not acceptable and then she stopped but
she was playing with that edge trying to
find out where fun is and you know can
how hard can I hit Grandpa she doesn't
bloody well know she kind of knows but
she needs to know exactly well I can't
let her get away with it because then
she's not fun to play with she has to
learn to come and give her Grandpa a
whack and exactly the way that elicits a
playful response and that isn't annoying
and so there's a very you know you might
think well it's pretty harsh judgment to
lay on a 5-year-old it's like no it's
not I would like her to be the most fun
kid to play with that she could be right
and so I'm not going to pretend that
it's okay when it's not not setting that
boundary is almost like a curse it is a
curse yeah there you go away we would
then how's she going to play with other
with other kids if she doesn't know the
they're not going to be as forgiving as
Grandpa definitely not in other news
this episode is brought to you by
manscaped if you are a gentleman who is
still using an old face shaver from
three Christmases ago to trim your
gentleman's area what are you doing join
us here in the modern world there are
purpose built tools for the job and the
brand new lawnmower 5.0 Ultra is the
tool that you need it's got a Cutting
Edge ceramic blade to reduce grooming
accidents a 90-minute battery so that
you can take a longer shave waterproof
technology so that you can groom in the
shower and an LED light which
illuminates grooming areas for a closer
and more precise trim or if you just
want to do it in the dark like a ninja
would going into the holiday season you
might want to get the man in your life a
gift or hint at him that he's a tiny bit
more hairy than you would like and the
manscaped lawn mower 5.0 Ultra is the
perfect blending of these two worlds
since we're on YouTube I can't show you
how this actually works but what I can
show you is that transformation right
there that's you gentlemen unwrap the
gift of smoothness this SE by going to
the link in the description below or
heading to manscaped.com wisdom using
the code wisdom a checkout for 20% off
and free shipping that's manscape.com
wisdom and wisdom at checkout thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that clip with Jordan you will love the
over 3-hour long podcast episode which
is available right here go
on give it a tap